if there was ever a site to epitomize a
sense of great loss and grief it was
tonight in solihull just meters away
from the icy lake that claimed the lives
of four young boys hundreds gathered
some quietly remembered
[Music]
some softly sang
[Music]
others held back tears
they all came to pay tribute to Thomas
Jack and brothers Finn and Sam now known
as the Babs Mill boys
just last Sunday they were together
playing but in tragic circumstances they
fell into a frozen lake their lives
unsavable it feels like they're my
children it's the most weirdest feeling
I've ever I've had two days three days
of just sleepless nights thinking about
them boys and thinking about what their
families are going through at this
present moment in time and the time and
the time of year as well it's just
horrible over the last week many in the
community paid their respects but
tonight they came from Beyond the Sea of
flowers grew even bigger and candles
little Shrine of tributes to remember
the local boys
it shows that people actually have a
heart if that makes sense especially the
way things eliminate like you don't
expect that many people to turn up but
people do care they obviously do
otherwise they won't be here just give
us a sense Gemma was asked by the
organizers to bring music to the vigil
on a cold Winter's evening it brought
some warmth
I think there's any words that could
describe as a mother myself a teacher
it's just um it's it's tragedy it's
um
it's something that hits everybody and
touched everybody so I think that
everyone has come together to support
the families because I couldn't imagine
what they're going through
perhaps most poignant was this image the
emergency services including some of
those who responded on Sunday paying
their own respects
the lake may look calm but it remains
icy and dangerous people in the area are
now calling for extra layers of security
the fencing just gives you a sense of
how concerned locals here are over the
last couple of days the community has
installed barriers and tape to try and
stop anyone else walking onto the lake
but there are concerns elsewhere too in
Telford bike marks were seen on a frozen
pool and Warwickshire police posted this
photo
urging people to stay clear what
happened to these four boys at Babs Mill
Lake should be a big enough deterrent
for anyone to stay off ice-topped Waters
their story has clearly devastated many
and will remain with people through
Winters to come into man Rashid Sky News
solihull